Thank you Greg. Now, as you may know, the rate at which we consume energy is
known as metabolism. When our energy stores and blood sugar levels have been
depleted, we have drives that tell us to replenish, and we do so by eating.
Hunger has four biological components. And those are the stomach, blood, brain
and hormones and neurochemicals. In addition to CCK, some other hormones
suppress appetite where as others stimulate it. Among those that suppress
appetite are leptin, peptide yy and insulin. Insulin has a very important
effect on hunger and its produced by the pancreas. As we eat, our blood glucose
levels rise, and insulin is produced. Insulin transports glucose out of the
blood and into the cells for energy use. As a result of increases in blood
glucose and insulin, hunger decreases.